[Music]
[Applause]
Reggie Bush just inducted into the
College Football Hall of Fame during the
National Football Foundation dinner in
Las Vegas last month and Reggie joining
us on the program before we get to
Reggie let's play the Reggie Bush game
the favorite NFL team he had when he was
growing up Todd I'll start with you I'm
going to say the Raiders okay
Satan man Raiders is a good guess I know
I agree uh I'm going to say the Raiders
all right Marvin I'm going say the
Chargers okay all right local Team all
right Paulie it's got to be the
Chargers I'm gonna go readers let's
bring in Reggie Bush to play the Reggie
Bush game your favorite team growing up
was it was the Chargers man San Diego
Chargers okay who was your favorite
running back growing up Barry Sanders um
he was a guy that I wanted to emulate my
game after he's a guy that I fell in
love with um he is a guy that really
like I felt like introduced me to the
game of football he was a first person
that really just captivated me when I
watched him on the screen but is that
something you can learn the way Barry
ran um yeah it is I I think if um you
know obviously takes a lot of hard work
dedication um but you know the way that
Barry moved to me it was just it was
pure artwork you know and it was um
you know there's a lot of you know
built-in instincts as well into it and a
lot of that plays into your vision and
so you know I think there are different
drills and things that you can work on
with with young kids as far as working
on their Vision how to use your
peripheral vision how to see things how
to set things up um and then you have to
work on the quick feed as well um and so
I think there is you know that you can
get to you know the level of what you
know Barry Sanders um was obviously it's
gonna take a lot of hard work dedication
and there's only one true Barry but yeah
you can definitely get there what was it
like when you met
him oh man it was it was Full Circle
moment for me um you know he's such a
humble guy and I think I I remember
meeting
him uh my I wasn't even drafted yet I
was actually about to get drafted and I
was in Detroit you remember when the
Super Bowl was in
Detroit um and I was out there for the
Super Bowl so and that's when I met
Barry Sanders for the first time and I
was just I was just overwhelmed it was a
full circle moment I couldn't believe I
was meeting my idol the guy that I just
always wanted to pattern my game after
and he was so humble you know and a lot
of times people talk about when you meet
your Heroes you know they they don't
always live up to that Barry Barry lived
up to it how biggest celebrities were
you guys at USC in in that
moment um I would say we were very big
um when you look at the we can talk
about just the sidelines alone right
every celebrity you know would come out
to our games um Snoop Dogg was always
there will farell was there Shaq was
there sometimes um you know and and it
was awesome man we were on that football
field in that Stadium you know we felt
like Gladiators and you know that was
the arena um that you know we love to
compete in and every game was sold out
you know 95 96,000 people what's the
most surreal moment you had when you
played
um I had a lot of them I had a lot of
them it's hard to to choose one because
there were a lot of games that I look
back on um that I just I I I I can't
believe it happened you know I think one
that sticks out is is the Notre Dame
game we played in NRE Dame um you know
winning that game in the last second you
know what is being dubbed as the bush
push um but you know it it was it was
awesome to go through that experience
you know with my brother with my
teammates uh with the coaches um you
know playing for the fans um and then
also at home you know I think uh some of
my memorable games were playing against
uh UCLA um because that was always our
last game of the season it was always a
cross town rivalry and we always wanted
to make sure that we saved a little bit
up just for UCLA so that we always have
bragging rights that we owned La you
know so so many so many uh memories you
know when I think about my time in USC
and I'm just so appreciative that I
stopped through there well I didn't know
if the NFL was a let down after playing
at
USC um I'll tell you what when I got to
when I got to fame wise Fame wise you
were more famous in college than you
were in the
NFL well I I'll say this when I got to
New Orleans um there wasn't there was an
explosion you know of of just the fan
base welcoming welcoming me with open
arms because you got to also remember
this is six months after five months
after Hurricane Katrina
and so me coming to the City of New
Orleans was a very big deal because one
the team hadn't been good in years and
if you remember they were called the ANS
you know people will refer to them as
the ANS and and fans would show up to
the games with paper bags over their
over their heads and and the team you
know I believe they had lost every game
the year before um so you know me coming
to New Orleans was a very big deal and
it was one of my favorite moments you
talk about a surreal moment that was a
surreal moment me going to New Orleans
um because I was supposed to be the
number one draft pick I don't know if
you remember yeah um and you know Tak
back down Mario Williams ended up being
the number one draft pick I actually
found out the same way everybody else
found out um I found out on Sport Center
was it because he was
signable like like that was the report
at the time no you want to know the
truth yeah the truth is with Charlie
Casserly and you know he he hasn't
talked about it you know we've actually
had an opportunity to discuss it uh when
I was working for NFL Network because
one of the executives found out the
truth and I hadn't even known the truth
yet uh about why I didn't go to Houston
and apparently it was because they hired
a private investigator to investigate me
during the Heisman Trophy um debacle
that was happening at that time an
investigator came back and said that I
was a bad guy had bad character I was a
street kid and um that they shouldn't
sign me they shouldn't draft me and so
this is a story I'm getting from one of
the executives at NFL Network um and so
you know they wanted to do this one
onone with me and Charlie cley and just
kind of talk about it and at first cley
said yeah and then he ended up backing
out because you know I think he
understood it probably you know wasn't
gonna look great for him so you know so
Charlie was the longtime GM of the then
Washington Redskins then he became a GM
of the Texans so they they had the
chance to take you number one how we're
talking to Reggie Bush how will you sum
up your college career talking to your
kids awesome amazing one of my favorite
stops um college is the place where I
learned so much about myself I became a
man um I had to overcome things I had to
compete I had to you know compete for
the for the you know for the role that I
ended up you know um immersing myself in
as you know starting running back and
punt returner and catching the ball to
the back field and all those different
things and so I had to work to get there
and um I was also surrounded by amazing
talent I was also surrounded by great
coaching and you know that was one of
the things that also helped elevate my
game as well is every time we stepped on
that practice field um it it we felt
like it was you know it was the
competition level was always at its
highest it was a it was almost it was
just straight competition you know what
I'm saying and and from the time that
the whistle was blown we always started
practice with 9 on7 I hated 9 on7
because it was like the defense was
you're not throwing the football 9 on7
um you know practice period it's just a
run it's just a run period it's a run
you're literally only running the ball
and the defense knows you can't throw it
you know and and so every linebacker is
sprinting full speed downhill soon as
the ball's hiked and it's like running
into a brick wall but that's what we did
to get our practices started during the
week you know as we prepared for Notre
Dame as we prepared for UCLA and as much
as we hated it it also made us stronger
and it also helped us to develop the
chemistry and the bond that we needed so
that we can go and win some of these
tough games Reggie inducted into the
College Football Hall of Fame during the
National Football Foundation dinner in
Las Vegas last month I agree with your
point about Nick sabbin if you'll
paraphrase that for the audience that
the reason why you think or at least one
of the reasons why Nick Sabin is
stepping down is because
it's because of nil um and if anybody's
been paying attention and if they've
been listening to Nick sabin's um you
know speeches or interviews that he's
been doing at some of these different
conferences and I don't know where he's
at when he's you know speaking um to you
know some of these people but um there
was a point to where he was complaining
about other universities paying players
he was complaining about Jimbo Fisher um
paying players he complained about Dion
Sanders supposedly paying you know five
star players and it was you know I I
honestly felt like at one point I didn't
understand it because on one side you're
looking at this is supposed to be one of
the greatest coaches ever in the history
of college football and here he is
complaining after he just won five six
national championships you know so I
never I didn't understand that mindset
of what are you complaining about you're
at the top you are the Pinnacle people
want to be you and yet here you are
complaining because the playing field is
now starting to level itself out and
that's what people have to understand
with nil that's what's happening there's
a movement that's happening and the
movement is the power is going back into
the hands of the players and that's
something that has never existed in
college football or Collegiate Sports
because it's been built off of
amateurism right and we know that it's
not true it's not true amateurism
because there's big money this is Big
Money business when we talk about
college football and when we talk about
college basketball it's big money it's a
big business is Dion Sanders what he's
doing at Colorado
sustainable um what what do you mean
like what part of is it sustainable
because right
now winning you know five six games a
year I think is sustainable um you know
I think if you're talking about winning
a national championship that's a much
tougher um subject in question because
um they just got to start getting better
recruits they got to start getting
five-star players and at the end of the
day that's what it comes down to you
know you can find you know here and
there sometimes some three star guys
maybe a two star guy here and there and
and turned him into a fourstar you know
player um but at the end of the day you
know to be able to win and to stay on
the top you need to be able to get those
fstar recruits you got to be able to get
those festar players and so he has that
position he has the most important
question answer which is the quarterback
position right now with his son um after
that you know he's got he's got to go
find some guys you know after his son
leavs because I think after this year
his son's probably gonna be gone um but
he's got to start getting better you
know better players and and that's you
know that's where it's tough because at
the end of the day now you look at the
Pack 12 is gone um I apologize I don't
even know what's where's Colorado going
now what conference are they going to
they're in the Big 12 they're going into
the Big 12 so um isn't that crazy that
we have no idea where like Texas and
Oklahoma are going to the SEC yeah I
know where they're going and you called
it the pack 10 or the Pack 12 and now
it's the pack two and like this crazy
crazy you know disappointing it really
is that the grown-ups have allowed this
to happen well you know it's again this
goes back to um the structure of college
football and and how it operates and the
narrative that um the NCAA has been able
been able to create with the
amateurism um word and being able to
really deceive I think people into
believing that it truly is amateurism
because it's truly not amateurism um
again like I said it's big money
business um and the players are the
workhorses and and for so long the
players did not have power um up until
most recently until the NCAA was
forced uh by the Supreme Court um with
the ruling of nine nothing to allow
players to monetize off of the thing
that they owned from the time that they
were born which was their name image and
likeness uh you filed a defamation
lawsuit against the NCAA was that in
August explain explain to me what you're
hoping to get out of that um listen the
NCAA made a statement about me um that
was a lie they said I was paid to play
um and that was never part of the
original investigation um alleging that
I was paid to play and so if it's a lie
then it's a lie um and for so long the
NCAA has been able to get away with the
narrative that I was paid to play that's
why it's it's ironic that the narrative
that I was paid to play was first
circulated and started by the very
people who released a statement about me
um officially you know stating that I
was paid to play and so that's what the
the lawsuit is over that's what the
defamation of lawsuit um ultimately is
about is about when you know some person
someone says something about you that's
not true um especially if it's public um
especially if it's released you know
to you know numerous media Outlets you
know that pick up on it and it's also
you know listed as a reason as why I'm
not being reinstated or a reason as why
you know I'm not getting my Heisman
Trophy back and that's a lie but what if
they what if they said drop your lawsuit
we'll restore your Collegiate records as
a settlement it's too late it's too we
we pass we way past that we pass the but
if they restore your records then you
get the Heisman they gonna have to do
that anyway that's G to happen anyway
all all that going to happen anyway
because again I don't know if you heard
what I said A Lie Is A Lie right and so
if it's a lie then is going to be
exposed right we'll find out in this
lawsuit you know what I'm saying we'll
find out who's really telling the truth
and that's what's the most amazing part
about it is we've never y' we've never
been able to do this for so long I've
never been I haven't been able to do
this which is you know father's lawsuit
against the NCAA until they made that
statement you know and so that's again
that's that's what you guys are seeing
now for the first time you're seeing my
story my case being tried in an an
official way you know in the court of
law which is something that the in has
never had to do they never had to prove
their case in the court of
law great to talk to you congratulations
going into the College Football Hall of
Fame good luck with the lawsuit thanks
for joining us thank you appreciate you
man that's Reggie Bush joining us on the
program they won the Heisman in 2005